welcome to the Monday night live show
and took a moment but I think everything
looks fine so let's get going and yeah
welcome to all of you in the chat I'm
going to be game started playing some
five-minute games and we start right
away against mr. Boris Oh place them the
eloquent self let's do this and see what
you plays on August 12
there's the world elephant day playing
the elephant gambit I did not think
about that and I don't think I will play
the elephant gambit I don't really think
this is a good opening to burst there
I'm kind of on my own yeah I have no
idea about this line I was just thinking
I wanted something else but that is
probably something that it's not so
great yeah we'll see will the Smith
Moore again that'd be making an
appearance mm-hmm I did not plan for
that to happen
is that good for black I mean he has a
hard time to develop his pieces here so
I'm taking here I mean I understand that
the d3 porn is an annoyance but still
how do I get there I mean I want to take
it clean to see for it's extremely it's
really simple
yeah I can't play Quintus you form I
mean that's not totally ridiculous let's
try it
I shouldn't fall for the Siberian trap
yeah the Siberian trap that's in the in
this myth Margaret okay so I should just
recapture this way I might develop the
bishop to be two words not bad
completely unknown position to me now
that's what you'll get with the Alec
Isles I think is a hard time to develop
here I don't really see how he gets us
pieces out you had this vision okay um
Bishop d3 Queen d3 this is possible in
g4
I can just click here right is there
something after g4 I can go Bishop b4
threatening Queen c6 pretty pretty a
funny funny game but just does work
right
the threat of Queen cake c6 is pretty
strong I think unless I'm missing stuff
check is not reacting to it what is the
point does he drop my bishop yeah Tommy
this is the Alekhine's defense it done
sometimes is just plain bonkers um after
a fun night of 693 and gap probably from
the d5 and then 97
yeah c6 was a good move I completely
blundered this
what did weird game that looks like a
completely like a random position a
completely rendom yeah 90 force what I'm
expecting and this is I didn't do that
huh
okay surprising so let's let's get rid
of this one first my bishop can go back
to e4 I mean I'm an exchange and a pawn
up so materialize this position is great
it's not like you can develop his pieces
all that easily
okay this is the thing but I thought
this move is doing it just cover it we
should be to next
but you did not find the link in the now
instead video that's weird
that's really weird because this is the
link is copy it's basically in to it so
I don't really see what he might be
broken there okay so you can take the
ship c6 just straight down stuff there
is no link in the text it's a clickable
field in YouTube if you look for a text
that's not in the text but isn't in the
text for a while because you can just
put it into into YouTube clickable
window and that should be on I mean
black like okay he just tosses him the
towel after the trades him and that was
a weird game okay next one yeah of
course you can just subscribe to the ICC
channel which is the easiest then you
can get notification and everything
about my streams this is easier
there is no clickable field that's
really strange I mean I had some problem
with it because um it was a little bit
rushed the posting of that video but
still I'm it I think it should have
worked
okay um but I'm glad that you found the
way here um one thing that I can't
mention right away to all the regulars
next week the next week's show and will
not be on Monday because Monday at 10:00
our regular time and this is when
Kasparov will be playing the the rapids
event in st. Louis so
going to do it at the same time than
Gary is playing that's not really not
really great so what we're doing is the
live show will be on Sunday Sunday 10:00
p.m. Central European Time or 4:00 p.m.
u.s. East Coast on Sunday so if you're
in Europe it's like right after you are
I don't know movie in the evening or
whatever you do so we just went to the
to the Sunday so that we don't collide
today okay
and we have the Newman's Own Yamhill my
knight c6 line from my book yeah
check it's not bad I could do a
commentary on Gary's play you know I
don't want to I want to watch myself
especially I want to watch the video
yeah I'm driving this space you on the
kingside yeah that's the thing
almost anybody will watch the official
livestream simply I mean with Kasparov
playing you need to have the video he's
just so fantastically expressive yeah
you just will be entertained to no end
okay and how do I rate
Gary's chances I I think I have to be
more precise I need to I would need to
see the precise field I think I mean I
think it's unlikely that evil and that
it will win the event yeah we have to be
realistic there but I think it is very
very much possible that he would have a
positive score which would be a success
really yeah I think there's the odd
player that is probably M yeah just just
a bit weaker to be honest like lik form
them more there's somebody else then you
do mean yes I mean very very strong
players but I think that Gary is so
probably better I mean I don't know but
it also rapid in blitz it's also a
different kind of thing than just a long
time control game when maybe stamina is
is also playing an important role and
this is probably where the younger
players have an edge what is he thinking
about
yeah I'm not really a huge fan of my
position it looks a little bit weird
yeah Corolla does not seem to be in good
shape I have to agree Marcus it looks
weird what is doing
yeah this question is of course very
very valid gem if Kasparov would come
out with time ago booty ranked in the
top 100 I mean we have to see look at
Vishy Anand right
I mean Ireland is is one of the one of
the top players still absolutely a top
world-class player and it could borrow
from is just 60 years older and this is
not a huge difference and Kasparov
always was extremely fit physically so I
hope I don't we don't really think that
he should be worse than on our gym
there's really no reason to believe that
still of course he's not going to do a
gem it's got nothing to to gain them
okay this is a really strange position
and I understand that that it is weird
and I put all the pawns on light squares
but there was it just how it happened
okay I will just take it I cannot take
it I think I can take it
I mean we should takes rook takes even
checkmate funny enough
there is no real move okay um so the
chick it's not made funny enough check
what
check this is going to win check some
more material white reason just a
strange game but all the sudden you fell
apart okay let's see
huh did Ben McDaniel TTT
why was he banned that's wrong the game
started he didn't do anything and okay
so I'm gonna fall against whatever okay
you know it cannot pronounce this name
go for the two nights that is a pretty
good line 96 it's just what it is
check yeah this is the end of my
preparation Bishop before I'm quite
[Music]
quite happy with
so just before maybe because probably
the citizen of Croatia yeah there was
something like that
I don't I don't really follow this
I mean he's living in the US right which
is castling wrong wrong
check you will probably try to put a
knight on to see form it looks it looks
very very lightly
I would like to go up c5 but he can take
that twice unfortunately doesn't look so
good check
and you get get look into play
yeah this variation is okay for black
that is true I agree but I don't really
happen don't have anything knives
against 39.6 like it's okay there I
think
the disposition is not bad I think check
okay so taking maybe not night b-2s
maybe possible why isn't the shawl not
banjee Adam I don't quite understand I
mean it's really not a big deal but I
don't understand why who killed someone
night between said happening and just go
back
it interesting the question if I could
go back in time what famous chess player
would I like to meet to that stuff I
mean most of the like world champions
they they are not supposed to be the
nicest people not quite sure
I've been Laden that's a good suggestion
by Tony that's true very interesting
play a very interesting character that's
real bent Larsen is a good one so what
is he doing there
Queeny five out for 96
[Music]
maybe this one I don't know I'm kind of
irritated here by this game couple
Blanca and also also interesting that
you're probably also would have been
interesting know may night eighty-four
and in ninety three is an immediate
threat and completely and miss playing
this nonsense that's very bad
I think this pollution was per totally
fine rather better for Wyatt than
anything else but I completely missed
later
yeah that is right
whatever 92 is a threat as well it just
blended the whole frame queenside for
for absolutely no real
who p1 I need I need a cheap trick on
the a5 it's the only thing I can imagine
half of the gear
rook b6 at least that looks looks like a
threat I mean he's God
Oh II did she just take okay
isn't this somewhat dangerous I thought
time warning
23 is playable
unfortunately check check check
check okay
white reason uh I was a terrible game ah
really really bad game from a very good
position I've went to a pretty terrible
position
Eddie masala so let's play Eddie masala
let's see what person is showing up it's
been to 2500 and back and it's always
very very retic games I mean what
definitely would be very interesting if
we talk about those like travelling back
in time and so on him it would be very
interesting to ya to be around let's say
in Vienna or Paris like between 1850 and
the early 20th century they had chess
and coffee houses and and many many
famous people on playing BB being around
and being involved with chess in some
way and we talking people like I mean
philosophers or even later on
yeah like politicians like Linnaean and
so on yeah it's really really
interesting this is this period of time
so you would probably meet lots of
famous players and people something not
just chess players and we are taking
this
yeah the the cafe Dilla visuals and
probably not doing this right the
pronunciation but yeah this this for
example I am one of those those coffee
houses in Indiana I'm just taking a
scent upon and she gives me one this is
the somewhat weaker version of Eddie
sometimes it's playing like superhuman
and then very human okay
there are no resting for me
of course not Monday show but that has
to be done
Bishop to D 1 where are you going with
this
[Music]
mmm can I just grab them on before I
would like to effect just take it but
it's not not that clear
and I can just covered
how many thunderlips accounts are there
and really weird I mean really good
nothing better to do with spending chess
show words really really poor I came
yeah what was said TMI on about I don't
know what that means actually throw it's
an internet jargon that I don't know
what with it some abbreviation that does
not it's not known to me
okay so proxy to have too much
information
okay okay so what happens this night is
actually reasonably safe I think this
will have just take a five referring to
his stomach he guesses yeah well he has
to have stomach gases I mean he's got
all the air in his head you know it has
to go somewhere probably this is not
just stopping at the head okay so t8
support the deep on and check this
take this yeah moving the night is a
little bit then there's before coming
didn't see that move before it was a
little strong keep the default on before
you pay for drops drops this thing drops
to be con be 395 Gras outside - offered
why why come to the seventh ranked check
check
check I can first improve us anymore
check check
booster let's push the pons
check-check
check-check it doesn't look like your
result check time morning check point
forfeits on time okay so it was a long
game at the end game so starting one
whole Chilean at play the same guy said
over and over but a plus to score
against them
let's see what he has in store against
this ultrasonic No
why you think what's going on here
2:56 that's a bit of a strange move it's
probably not terrible but what what is
the point that is the point
really okay so let's say look you won I
don't understand this person he always
plays like the most ambitious stuff ever
here there's never a normal move like
it's really strange
it's always something fancy and it can
never be just develop the piece also has
to be the most complicated stuff ever
that probably never works but still
let's try it
okay so Bishop f4 looks normal him let's
do it
yeah one day Bishop Keeks b2 is
happening I need something to drink
ready to pick
yeah anyway kill young I'm going to or
does it take more time I think he's
taking more time
[Music]
okay so you snitch the Trillian pawn
what do you want
so just take stuff if somebody is if I
mean this guy is always guilty of fancy
place syndrome again it's never a normal
move never ever this one maybe I mean
it's a it's a pawn at the end I know
maybe had something better it's a pawn
shed
vodka obviously and no
so yeah this is actually not to dismiss
off
Bendis troll what troll obviously okay
what am I doing here I was threatening
to take on a seven Brook a success maybe
coming
maybe I should have just played roopd
six instead now that I think of it
you should be 65 yeah whoo a couple of
options check
yeah it's sparkling water and as you
there often say just with gas or without
gas
yep
see six try and look be seven maybe I
should have gone to g3m now that I think
of it to to tseebo to see three would
have been much more logical I wanted to
cover this but this appointment I don't
need to cover it I need to promote it
now let's attack the April I cannot
cover it anymore
yes he's several or not I think I can
still try to keep the pawn with Bishop
f4 next yeah I should probably keep it I
know you can take F to it the C pawn is
quite quite good to have I think so be
Sam and then just roughly eight next
very will sacrifice the exchange that's
pretty stupid 1e just take a five
this relook this server I really
displayed that really quite a bit I mean
I think it's ooh should win but that was
quite unnecessary to even get here I
mean
you
look t7 then we'll be a does my idea
age 4 would be 8 check check check check
check check check
black for fix on time to do it on time
with 2 seconds
I'm not trying to find the best moves
anyway that had the result that it
should have at the end but ever they
move yeah didn't do it all that well
let's go for the next game should have
gotten a glass but you wouldn't want to
leave the place again the technical
masterpiece yes absolutely a freak with
it that was really bad
technically speaking yeah do we have any
cool game started ok let's stroll in
with f5 and a gift
how does that work I think you get in
six bag I actually kept this in the
tournament game once
yeah I'll get I'll get e6 I don't think
Bishop e3 is good he still plays at who
can you do this there's some food
discussion in the chat that I don't
follow
what would I you what are you talking
about
and yep activate this
that looks really really Wow Wow
I didn't think this was possible at
least I thought that this is looking
really strange for white but maybe I am
wrong
I am probably wrong but this is still
kind of funky I had a weird idea here
that didn't work
first they take on a fourth but of
course this is totally ridiculous it is
completely ridiculous
now how unnecessary and this is one of
those persons I always win against I've
got like a 90% so against not a good way
to play against such a person
just f3 and I'm in very bad shape
[Applause]
[Music]
and maybe you can get in some trickery
here with Knight f5 and Zahn I saw that
d6 is hanging but I thought it doesn't
really matter or that much anymore still
taking some time here I believe but we
treat it's not an option
I also have to speed up I mean okay I'm
not too unhappy about this getting at
least this not even the ending is
totally totally simple I don't want you
to want the ending though
yeah it sure looks bad Wow he wants to
trade Queens real badly okay
then again they're not happy with this
but
I can check me here and so on that
doesn't feel good
I shouldn't have trade twins maybe
yeah everything wins that makes it
difficult you just Nate teak stuff is
probably correct this is not good but
probably good enough
[Music]
[Music]
is doing all kinds of things to make
life difficult you could have taken b7 I
don't know why he didn't I mean you can
push these points here and that makes it
tough for me quite clearly but still
time warning was for straightening have
you absolutely bad technical play is
another looking at five M
[Music]
check-check
what is the legal game it was really bad
every need
anyway I mean I was so totally lost and
he allowed tons of stuff but it was
still it was still lost this is how bad
it was okay yeah I can just for example
I can just take seven to check for
starters but it's probably so bad it
doesn't matter okay um who else is on
casters on its a frequent opponent
hoagies on it okay
I don't get dance started like una Fox
what is he doing
Sicilian this is the interesting line by
the way
it's a little bit yeah
I'm typical as I'm giving up the M help
me out here
the bishop a up with it but why it gets
excellent development and it's not easy
at all for like like yeah castles Bishop
h6 like already I think has screwed up a
little bit
[Music]
okay no castle for you at least not for
the moment
okay so I have Queen b3 is actually an
interesting move
why not threatening Bishop g7 and
preventing we should be six for the
moment okay I want to get the knight
onto a dark square Bishop e6 you
and there is no way to prevent it
yeah Tony awright see 423 is good
against the calm
there wasn't a candle lit but you're
right about it at least I have the same
opinion okay so the eight how do I get
the night night to see five would be
great
maybe just put it back
I probably should have played 93 going
for the dark squares much earlier yellow
Sicilian car has one distinct difference
to many other Sicilian lines there's
just not there's no line where why does
canceling lawns and would attack you
like crazy
that doesn't happen on the other hand
you've got the Hedgehog which is also
not everybody's cup of tea
yeah here black it's like it's not able
to do much maybe a book t6 is a move now
let her think of it
[Music]
yeah the music it in streams but Eric
hands and that adds really tough this is
I mean it's a matter of taste obviously
it's not mine
but of course they can do whatever they
want in their streams and people I mean
if they if people like it why not in
what's going on down hoop d8 if he
enters with the Queen I could be in some
perpetual check trouble yeah but how
likely is that he's got to uncheck or to
it and what helps keep it's a video with
rowdy or youngster I don't know I mean
now I don't like the guy but I don't
think this would be appropriate
he's not on right nope
yeah Kuna Fox is running out of moves
here it seems it's difficult for him to
ever move the bishop so like let's say I
take on f/8 and then Queen to c7 where
are you coming with the bishop ever ok
and now yeah the problem with this kind
of stuff should be that I'm attacking
with Knight and green isn't that
annoying 97 for example yeah but I think
this is good anyway
Queen a - oh my god Queen a - this is
this is looking bad if you get this one
I mean I have 97
97's couch
wow what the heck what's going on here
and row contracts and then we should be
hired back or maybe
tie morning just want to put it here
black for cents on time yeah I know some
time which it takes you to or Service
Above Self says maybe era maybe there
was something like that it's possible it
was really possible the move I'm a
little bit annoyed about instead this
one I should just put this here and have
this idea there would have been much
better I think yeah anyway guys thanks
for watching the show we already
10-minute sum over J 11 here on my end
and make sure to get to adjust your
calendars the next show is not on Monday
but on Sunday so it will be Sunday the
hmm
you know like Sunday not Monday the same
time there will know Sinquefield cup
action that's one day before they start
with the reputable it's tournament there
would also be the final show for break
of three weeks as I'm away on holidays
be on vacation so yeah make sure to tune
in and yeah see you on Sunday my wife
you